team gp have won their first olympic
medals
at the tokyo games first chelsea giles
took bronze in the judo and then in just
the last few minutes
bradley sindin won the silver in the
taekwondo
tom parmenter sports correspondent
joining me now from tokyo
tom we can start celebrating now coming
because for so long it's been all about
the delays and the controversy and this
is the bit the athletes wanted to get to
it was a thrilling final in the
taekwondo that has just finished as you
say bradley
sinden taking silva he was so close to
taking gold against a very good
competitor from uzbekistan
and he just it went a few different ways
throughout that final he was up he was
down he was up again
and sadly bradley has just missed out on
the goal but a
cr incredible effort from him to take
silver
britain's second medal of the day here
he's from stanford near doncaster in
south yorkshire where they've been
watching
very very closely indeed delighted to
see him succeed in getting to the final
outperforming expectations and really
making up for
a difficult day in the taekwondo so a
good
weekend i think now based on those
medals but
there have been those disappointments
along the way andy murray has had to
pull out due to a muscle strain
of the singles but he'll continue in the
doubles we've seen victories
in the boxing today that squad is going
well for team gb
and a big moment in the skateboarding
street skateboarding
arrived at the olympics and the first
gold medal in that
competition went to japan went to the
son of a tokyo taxi driver
who took the first ever skateboarding
medal in the olympic games quite a
weekend of sporting action but team gb
have a bronze and now a silver medal as
well